we have to hand it to you zendaya you're
truly one of a kind it's super rare for
Disney Channel stars to become producers
on their very own shows
but somehow you managed to pull it off
you're one of our favorite Disney stars
of all time and the Disney Channel just
hasn't been the same without you
luckily we can watch reruns of Casey
Undercover whenever we want and when we
get bored with that we can always check
out one of your many new films you're
starring in we were totally bummed when
we found out that zendaya was packing
her bags and leaving the Disney Channel
for good but as it turns out this star
had some pretty shocking reasons for
leaving watch until the end to find out
what the Disney Channel did to lose one
of its brightest stars it's no secret
that working for the Disney Channel has
its ups and downs on one hand do you
quickly shoot to stardom and connect
with some truly talented people but on
the other hand you don't always get
taken seriously and you have to obey a
handful of restrictive rules still that
seems like a small price to pay for
stardom Sunday I became interested in
the Disney Channel when she was 13 years
old and by the time she was 14 she had
already been cast in Disney's shake it
up alongside bella thorne this was a
dream come true for zendaya until it
became somewhat of a nightmare from 2010
to 2013 zendaya appeared in a handful of
Disney Channel shows but something just
wasn't right it soon became public
knowledge that zendaya and Bella didn't
get along throughout the first season of
their show but by the time season 2
rolled around the girls were BFFs so
what happened
well according to Bella she and Sandhya
were constantly forced to compete
against each other and the network
thrived on this
luckily the girls worked things out
amongst themselves but the unjustified
rivalry left a bad taste in Zendaya's
mouth it didn't take long for the
outside world to notice just how
beautiful and talented zendaya truly is
so many opportunities came knocking on
Zendaya's door but instead of becoming
the Hollywood after she was meant to be
sindhya chose to stick by the Disney
Channel side in 2014
daya was cast as KC Cooper in the TV
series KC undercover a show that would
air for a total of three seasons Sunday
as fans were totally upset when she
announced that KC undercover was coming
to an end after three short seasons
although Disney Channel shows hardly
ever go past four seasons fans felt as
though the show was cut too soon but as
it turns out Sunday I had her reasons
for leaving the Cooper's behind after
announcing that the TV series was coming
to a close
zendaya also revealed that she would be
leaving the Disney Channel we're good
and surprisingly she also admitted to
almost having left the Disney Channel
directly after shake it up ended zendaya
threatened to leave the Disney Channel
because she felt as though the network
wasn't inclusive enough during an
interview with Glamour magazine Sandhya
opened up about being disappointed that
there weren't any all-black families on
the Disney Channel
zendaya talked about how important it is
for people of color to grow up seeing
themselves in the mainstream media this
is my ID you need to come with me Disney
listened and decided to create KC
undercover but that wasn't enough for
zendaya she wanted to make sure that the
sitcom would be everything she wanted
from a TV show and more so she's somehow
convinced Disney Channel executives to
make her a producer on the show this way
she would have a say on everything and
anything that went down on the sitcom
this was truly a triumph on Sunday as
part because it's old news that the
Disney Channel doesn't let their actors
have a lot of creative freedom over the
show's that they're cast in just ask the
Sprouse twins if you don't believe us
hands where we can see them Casey Casey
Cooper despite having tons of offers
from the outside world Sunday a chose to
remain on the Disney Channel to pose as
KC Cooper and for three years kids
tweens and teens were happy to see a
family of color flash across their
screen but on February 2nd 2018 sindhya
took to Twitter to announce that tonight
would be the last episode of Casey and
therefore her last episode on the Disney
Channel Sunday it took things a step
further when she thanked her fans for
growing with her and explained that this
was the end of an
era the last season of kc undercover was
filmed in 2017 and that's when zendaya
started landing new movie roles left
right and center she was cast as
Michelle in spider-man homecoming as
well as Ann wheeler in the greatest
showman on top of that zendaya became
interested in modeling which quickly
proved to be a successful avenue while
it's true that zendaya left the Disney
Channel because she was ready to move on
to bigger and better things there's more
to the story than just that
Sandhya was also tired of being
considered as a Disney stars she
revealed that having a Disney past can
sometimes make it difficult for people
to take her seriously she explained that
she has to be super selective when it
comes to movie roles and seeing as India
wants to accomplish a lot more in the
movie industry it was time for her to go
out in the real world so there you have
it guys
the real reason zendaya left the Disney
Channel showcase the undercover before
you go tell us which one of Sunday's
roles is your favorite in the comments
section below give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things thanks for watching we'll
catch you later
[Music]